Welcome everyone. I'm Priya Natarajan,
an astrophysicist on the faculty in the Department of Astronomy and Physics at Yale.
I also serve as the current Director of Yale's flagship interdisciplinary program,
the Franke Program in Science and the Humanities.
I'm delighted to have you all attend to
these wonderful talk by a neuroscientist and author,
Mariano Sigman, as part of our ongoing mapping as knowing series.
I want to first start by recognizing the generosity
of Mr. and Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke,
for endowing this program and many other activities at Yale.
As a quick point of reminder,
since we are recording this event,
I would like to request you all to mute your videos and microphones.
Please go ahead and submit your questions for our speaker through the Q&A feature.
Dr. Ty Kamp and I will relay these questions to him after the talk.
Coming to our speaker today,
Dr. Mariano Sigman is an eminent neuroscientist with
well over 150 publications and some of the most prestigious scientific journals.
He's extremely research active.
He's also very passionate about experimentation and has worked on
an unusually large set of collaborators that might sound really peculiar and intriguing;
magicians, chess masters,
musicians, athletes, and visual artists,
to bring his knowledge of neuroscience to
different aspects of human culture and activity,
and apply it in different contexts.
He has participated several times in the TEDGlobal events in Vancouver.
In one of these instances,
he participated with then [inaudible].
In his conferences, he teaches how the mind works and
what lessons we can learn about decision-making, leadership, team management,
personal development or creative skills,
and his presentations always end up with a high level of
participation from the audience through experiments and gamification.
Dr. Sigman obtained his degree in physics from the University of Buenos Aires,
his doctorate in neuroscience in New York,
and he did a post-doc in cognitive sciences at the College de France in Paris.
In 2016, he was awarded the PO11 medal from the Pontifical Academy of Science,
which is a major science prize.
Previous winners include Stephen Hawking and many notable Nobel Prize winners.
Beyond the academy, his research has had practical implications for medicine,
for clinical treatments,
for example, in the diagnosis of vegetative or autistic patients.
He's also had a lot of impact in education,
with effective interventions to improve
decision-making and learning in schools throughout Latin America,
and in art with a project at
the morphology of the look that has been exhibited now in New York,
Austria, Moscow, Mexico,
Japan, and was part of the 2017 Venice Biennale.
He's also developed an extensive career in the public dissemination
of science that includes multitude of TV programs,
hundreds of articles published in different editorial media.
He's also the author of the bestseller The Secret Life of the Mind.
I highly recommend this book.
Absolutely fell in love with it.
It's just beautifully written.
Before turning over the floor to him,
I would just like to remind you all about our learning by doing project.
Please do consider submitting your videos to
our collection of simple science experiments.
Our final talk in the inference series will be given by
physicist Kyle Cranmer next week on December 15th at 3:00 PM.
Without further ado, I would like to turn over to Mariano, welcome.
We wish we could have welcomed you in person.
We had been postponing get your talk,
hoping that we could get you in person,
but then ultimately decided that we didn't want to wait
any longer and that we're dying to hear you.
Look forward to your talk. Thank you.
Thank you so much Priya for such a warm introduction.
I also would very much like to be able to be there.
I went to New Haven.
When I was a child, my aunt,
she was a neurologist and she worked there at Yale actually.
I went there as a child, and you know how we build
these child memories of these places as a bit mythical.
For me, my aunt was a huge intellectual and a great neurologist.
This place was the place where great scientists went.
I've never gone back, interesting.
I spent many years in the US in academia and I've been in many of the universities,
but I just brought these memory that for some reason I never came back to Yale.
I very much hope will have the opportunity,
I would very much wish to go there again.
We look forward to your visit in person.
This has brought me a very emotional memory from my childhood.
I'm going to speak about decision-making.
This series builds on the relation between mapping and knowledge.
I felt it would be interesting to begin,
not so much with the science of decision,
but the other way around, how science has helped us make decisions in difficult domains.
I think this has been often the role of science to
bring relevant data for having informed policies and informed decisions.
This has happened in all fields of knowledge,
and of course this includes neuroscience and
especially the breach or the relation between neuroscience and medicine.
Priya, you mentioned the work we've done on diagnosis of vegetative state patients.
I think this is a very clear case,
where many years ago there was not
much that could be done because essentially we're looking at devoid,
and technology has changed in a way that now we have the capacity to
be able to infer thoughts of other people by looking at their brains.
This is a technology that may be flashy and interesting,
but it gets really relevant when this is the only way
that we have to communicate with some people.
This happens in three very peculiar domains.
One is comatose patients or patients in
vegetative states where it looks like they are unconscious,
but we are really not sure if they're unconscious.
They do not express consciousness,
but of course that doesn't mean they do not have consciousness.
Another example I'll be showing some data is on babies,
when they're previable and they cannot communicate their minds.
As parents, we do all what we can to understand what they feel,
what they want, what they suffer,
what they desire,
and we do this exercise of complicated inference
where once again technology now can give us a good hand.
The third case, which I will not be speaking today, is dreams,
which also remains I think one of
the very interesting frontiers of knowledge in human neuroscience.
Let me start with work done by Adrian Owen.
This is an extremely classic paper,
has now 25 years.
What you're seeing there is the brain image by fMRI of the group of people.
This is the average image,
and it's been thresholded,
so the pattern of course it would be much more complicated.
But what you see on your left of the screen
here is what activates when someone imagines that plays tennis.
This is nothing special about tennis,
it has to do with motor actions.
What you see here, lightened,
is a region in the brain called the supplementary motor area.
This is a region that is involved with the coordination of movement.
But even if we do not enact these movements and we just imagine them,
then this region also plays this enroll.
It's like a music director that's directing the concert without its sounding.
On the right you see how the brain of a person
activates when they close their eyes and they imagine they are walking in their houses,
or they're walking in the Yale campus,
or they're going from their house to their work.
We have very significant capacity.
This comes from our ancestors broadens and all mammals to
navigate in space and their brain regions that are dedicated to this.
I'm not so interested now in the brain science of these specific functions.
What I'm interested in is that now if you see these from an engineering perspective,
now what we have is a utility, a tool,
a technology, that somehow we can tell very
rudimentary what the person is thinking just by looking at their brains.
Think whatever you want, either that you are playing tennis or that you
are walking in your house,
then I could tell with
very high probability what is actually what you are thinking just looking at your brain.
Again, this is not very useful like we just ask you that.
But once again, we come to the vegetative state patients.
We cannot ask them about their thoughts,
but somehow we can prompt them to make thoughts and then ask what happens.
Vegetative state patients they have been in the public scene for many years now.
The reason for this,
the first one is a purely medical reason,
which is that 20 years ago,
these patients arrived in a coma to
a hospital and their likelihood of survival was very low.
Now they survived, but they do so in a situation which once again,
it's a huge mystery about what goes on,
and this is situation which of course leads to
a lot of ethical problems, a lot of suffering.
Adrian Owen redid this experiment now with one patient that had
been five years completely uncommunicated and
with the idea that she was enabled to make explicit thoughts.
What if she could but she could not communicate them?
Could it be that reading their minds by MRI could detect that and that's what Adrian did?
What he found is that when he asked
this patient to imagine that she play tennis or that she moved,
apparently, she heard these message and she reacted and she
enacted this motion and the same thing with a spatial navigation.
Of course, we do not know whether they're conscious about this thought,
it could be that they're unconscious.
But at least we know that they understand something and they can react to that.
Once you have this tool,
this is an engineering device that you can use now as a binary communication device.
You can say whenever you want to say yes,
imagine that you play tennis,
whenever you want to say no,
then imagine that you're walking in your house.
As any communication device you want to calibrate it,
and you want to calibrate with things that you know,
so you'll ask questions like, are you a woman?
The answer is true, so you expect the answer to be yes.
Are you younger than 23? The answer is no.
Do you have three siblings?
The answer is no, and so on.
Once you have calibrated this communication device,
which is far from perfect,
but it's also much better than chance,
then you can start asking the questions that you would like to ask.
Are you suffering? What would you want?
What would you wish? What would you want us to do?
Then we go to a completely different sphere, the sphere of ethics,
but it's one that's nurtured or that can be
fueled by data that can be provided by science.
This is of course a very important but also a very tough example.
Let me now give you are much candid one, one which I think,
we all, at least for all of us,
with our parents, we've grown through this experience.
What you're seeing here is again,
the same strategy as I showed you before.
First, the brain of a person in which the experiment is so to say, easy.
This experiment is just the person listening to sentences.
You can imagine these as what happens in your brain as you're listening me to speak.
What happens is that you see this pattern of incubations in these two big region,
this is the auditory cortices and of course
we have the cortices activated when you hear sound.
Also interestingly I can not go into details of this,
but you see even if this is an old paper,
we were pushing the limits of temporal resolution.
You may know that if MRI is pretty decently good in spatial resolution,
you can get these maps which act like millimeter resolution,
but the temporal resolution is very low.
Cognition happens in a fraction of a second and suddenly you
have a tool that actually had a resolution of a few seconds.
We were in the frontier of these and what you see here in
different colors is not the amount of activity,
which is what you typically see in an fMRI image,
but the timing of activity,
and you see going from, this is measured by the magnetic signal,
which is the MRI response and they measure the phase of
this signal by convolving the response function and we could compute with these,
or we could infer the temporality of the responses.
What you see, once again,
this is a very fast summary of something that could be an entire talk.
You see that there's an early activation in the cortex
which projects to this region in the frontal left cortex,
very famous region you may have heard about,
called the Broca region.
It's named Broca by French neurologist Broca.
This region is known to be relevant and it's one of
the very highly specialized regions in the brain
which is specialized for the articulation of language.
If you have a fascia,
which means that you can understand language,
but you cannot produce language,
then typically you will have lesions in the Broca,
people that have fascia have lesions in the Broca region.
Now, if you've been following the logic of what I said,
there is something that may seem a bit strange because I'm saying this is the brain,
the activations in brain of people listening to sentences,
and yet they're activating one region which is
known to be very specialized for the production of sentences,
which they're not making, they're just listening.
As it happens with something that we've discovered or might not be entire field,
is that there is a whole system of resonance called the
mirror system in the human brain and in the mammal brain,
which is that essentially we internalize all the actions
you perceive by enacting them somehow.
In a way when we hear two sentences,
we're also producing internally and silently these sentences.
It's a little bit like I showed you in the previous slide when I said,
when you imagine that you're playing tennis,
you're not moving the muscles,
yet you're enacting the entire motor concert.
Now the question is, what happens with young babies when they listen to sentences?
Because it's not that they will not produce languages that they can't.
They have three months.
They have to quadruple their lifetime to
arrive to the moment in which they'll begin producing their first words and sentences.
Is preverbal baby very far from the moment of
the initiation of production of language, silently producing language.
This was a philosophical question,
one that was not amenable to science.
Now we have proxies.
We cannot completely answer this question,
but we have good ways of addressing this question,
which is repeating this exact experiment in babies and asking whether,
is their Broca region already being activated,
the region that actually works in the production of sentences.
Now what you have is a summary of three month old babies.
Once again, for those that have not experienced with babies,
they are very far from producing language and yet on a way they're trying.
I would like to present something which for me is very important here,
which is, this experiment I did just before I had my first child.
I thought it was very important because I think in a way,
a very essential thing of parenthood is that we try to detect
the struggles that our children may be undergoing, and we help them.
If they are struggling with walking, we give them a hand.
If they are struggling with eating, we'll help them on that,
but of course they're going through a million of struggles that we will never see.
Because they're [inaudible], they are silent.
I really like this experiment,
not only because of its scientific pertinence,
because I thought it communicate me better.
It's what I like most of neuroscience,
which is this capacity of getting
closer to the people that we would like eventually to get closer.
On a way, what this short story and I did exaggerate it of these result,
is that in the same way the nine month old baby
is trying to walk and they are struggling,
a three month old baby,
although this is silent, they're trying to speak,
they're trying to make their first words,
so I accompany,
I work with my son on this particular process.
This is just the way also on how science may be informing us on policies for education.
Now not education in school,
but maybe even more relevant for the patient,
which is parental education.
This is the first part of my talk and it has a different flavor, because once again,
it's not so much the neuroscience of decisions,
but it's the neuroscience that can help us,
or it will give us information to make better decisions.
Now I would like to go to a completely different space of decisions,
which is the ones, we do not have this technology and this much information,
the majority of the decisions we make, which is,
somehow we have the information that we have, scarce information,
often not enough, sometimes even no information,
and we have to make the best educated guess from what we have.
Let me give you a first example of what
we humans do when we are confronted with these type of decisions,
then we'll go into the science of it,
and then we'll go on to how we can improve some of
the biases and some irrationalities that we tend to make these decisions.
This is a very classic experiment.
I love this experiment, I would like to do it with you on stage.
It'd be much more interesting because we would sense it on a much better way.
It's a very classic demonstration.
The first end of scientific paper was published by Hubbard and Ramachandran,
at UCSD, University of California and San Diego.
The question is, these are two shapes,
one is bouba and the other one is kiki.
You know which one is which,
but the task for you decision-makers is to tell me which is which.
You can do this in the chat if you want.
You get that feeling,
you've got a public chat.
If you do then you could do it.
Then you may have a public sense of the agreement that there isn't the response of these,
typically 98 or 99 percent of the people agree that this is kiki and this is bouba.
This is quite interesting because it feels like completely
obvious as if it could not be in a different way.
Yet, when we are asked why is the case,
it's just very hard because there is no reason for that.
Some people do see a k here,
but if I would say titi instead of kiki,
then it will be the same thing.
The reason is known. The reason is that when we make sounds, we move the mouth.
When we move the mouth, the mouth gives different shapes.
When I go, O, or U,
those are called rounded vowels,
so we think that the sounds correspond to rounded shapes.
Instead, when we make these sounds in which the [inaudible] contracts in a sharp way,
like [inaudible], then we imagine that this sounds
are attacking consonants and are the ones that have sharp angles.
When I say there is this correspondence,
by no way that means that we are making these conscious logical inference.
I'm saying, the brain is doing this calculation,
we're completely unaware of it.
It biases our decisions in an extremely predictable and reliable way,
yet we are completely unaware of this entire process.
Now, this looks like a game and it doesn't look very important,
but let me give you an example which I think it's much more relevant and you'll see
how these same ideas start forging our decisions,
from the main thing which we maybe would not like them to do so.
Here, this is, once again,
I mentioned Alexander Todorov, he's in Princeton.
I think point to a specific paper because it's a collection of papers,
and this is my own demonstration from histories or east reference.
If you can look at any of his many papers.
He's been showing how we make judgments about
people of all sorts from facial expressions.
The way I like to frame this experiment,
is imagine you have a suitcase with like the most important things in your life.
Actually an interesting term it is,
what would you put in this particular suitcase?
What are the most important things in your life that you put in the small space.
But imagine you look and so unfortunate strange reason doesn't matter here.
You need to leave the suitcase with the most important things in your life.
You're confronted with the situation,
you have to respond very rapidly,
and you have to decide there's these three persons here.
You can think this as an investment problem.
You have your money, you choose what bank to put it on.
Each of these is one bank.
This is like the technical way of thinking this experiment.
The more real way would be you have something,
a real thing and you have to give it to one of these three people.
The question is, to whom you would give it to?
Here it's not so such as sharp distribution as we saw before.
But there's also very significant trend that's
observed in children and adults in America and Europe,
all over different cultures and so on.
Which is that the majority of the people prefer to give it to the person in the center.
The reasons why they do not give it.
Some people will give it to the person on the right,
and so people do person the left.
But the reasoning beyond this particular decision is that the person on the right,
we do not trust him so much,
like we have the impression that we may come back and ask for a suitcase and he may go,
"You know what, I like your suitcase and I will not give it back to you".
We do not want to go through this confrontation with this particular person.
The reason why the majority of the people do not
give it to the person on the left is very different.
Is we think he's like so naive,
that he will give it back to us,
or maybe he would give it to anyone,
and he will lose it,
or he'll be in this case.
Now, the interesting thing is, I mean,
I think you get the point that the majority of us do
make these very fast and rapid inferences,
and the interesting point is that we have no idea about these people.
We have not a single piece of evidence about how they would behave.
Yet, we make conclusions and conclusions in which
the majority of the people is highly confident,
really trust this impression of what the right action should be.
It could be. It's possible,
it's not impossible that the faces of actually you can see also that this,
it's the same person that has been only changed
the curvature of the mouth and the eyebrows and so on.
Now, it could be that there is a correlation
between people's faces and people's attitudes.
I mean, this is not impossible, but it's not true.
I mean, the Nobel Prize Kaniban,
Austin Princeton has shown
many times that these correlations actually do not hold in any way.
The conclusions that we make so strongly by people's appearances are completely
ungrounded and they leave it to completely wrong decisions in which we deeply trust.
Now, the example of [inaudible] was again,
this is very relevant because for instance,
it's known that the face of a person shapes elections.
If I were to show you two candidates of a completely unknown county of Australia,
and ask you who you think will win.
You'll be 55 or 60 percent,
and what this means is that only by the information in
the face is what the voters are using to make their choices.
Because you have no idea of who is a Democrat,
who's a Republican, who's progresses,
who is conservative, who has a good history.
No information at all, only with information of the face.
You can make this sort of conclusion.
Also, it's very well known in human resources.
The majority of the people decide
who to hire on the first 500 milliseconds of an interview.
Then they spend 20 minutes only to justify the decision that they have already made.
So I've given you two examples.
I could give you 20.
I mean, there are millions of them. There are funny examples.
What's consistent about these examples is how we are very stereotypical.
People call it irrational.
I don't think it's irrational because there is rationality,
only that we are doing rationality on the wrong ground.
On the wrong evidence,
and on the wrong information.
But there's a smart inference process.
But that takes us with very high confidence to a wrong conclusions.
Now what I would like to do is to tell you how this process builds.
How we actually build these intuitions.
Once again, I'm bringing you some classes, A or B field.
This is an experiment that you see now has 20 something years.
It was done by Befarer and Benacio very,
very famous experiment,
in which they tried to understand how we
construct these hunches and these conscious intuitions.
I think it's a very beautiful experiment.
Let me tell you exactly how it goes.
It's also an investment experiment.
The way it goes is that people are given two decks,
and these decks have payoffs.
These payoffs can be either positive or negative.
You can win money or it can lose money.
It's a simulation of you have to choose between two portfolios in stocks.
You can choose between them and sometimes you win, sometimes you lose.
You'll try to do some statistic or learning to understand,
on average what's the right policy, and that's what people do.
They choose from one,
they win. So they persist.
This is very typical then they win again,
they persist, we've made this inference, and we've won,
there's no reason to explore which is not optimal,
but that's what people do with your winning,
here you're very unlikely to go elsewhere.
Eventually you lose,
and then people do the contrary, they overswitch.
They go to the other deck and they play here
for a little while and then they lose and they switch and so on.
After an hour of play or something,
they reached this moment here,
which is the conceptual moment.
It happens that one of the decks has a highest average of return than the other one.
This is what's called the correct choice,
because it's the one that on average,
if you continue playing on this,
regardless of the stochasticity which you cannot control.
It is the policy that will give you a higher expected value.
Indian of these mini-trials,
people choose from the right bank,
and when you ask them why they are doing so,
they go up, they explain exactly what I just saw.
Well, you know, you win,
you lose, but on average these one is better than the other ones.
They have understanding and they understood the problem perfectly well.
What is interesting is how is the path to this particular moment.
Some trials before that,
there is a moment that the mass equals the hunch moment,
which is the following; people play from the right deck,
and if you ask them what they are doing.
They say, "Well, I'm playing from this one, I'm choosing from the right".
Why? I don't know,
I have this feeling that's the right thing to do, but I cannot tell you.
I mean, it's just a bad feeling I have had.
There you understand the genesis of the bad feelings.
They have nothing esoteric,
nothing mystical, nothing irrational.
It's a full-blown statistical learning process,
which yet has not come into works.
The brain has learned something and there's no mystery as to
why has learned something because it can be statistical information to learn it.
But this knowledge, as the majority of knowledge we have,
cannot yet be explained in a way that we can teach it in a lecture.
It's not explicit knowledge, is implicit knowledge.
We'd like to give you a feel of what intuitions are.
Intuitions are essentially a form of learning.
Statistical learning of different domains
and different disciplines, different scenarios,
and different portions of the universe,
which yet we have not made to explicit knowledge.
Now there is an even more interesting phase,
which is what Damasio called the pre-hand, which is the following.
In this phase, people as you see, are choosing,
on average a little bit more from the right deck than from the wrong deck.
But they don't even know they're doing that.
If you ask them what they are doing,
they will tell you I'm just picking a chance,
I'm going one and the other one I'm trying to learn.
There's no information,
no structure. That's not what they're doing.
They're picking more from the right.
Brain has this information.
This has not yet in terms of body expressions of wrong and right decision.
There is not even this information,
but they do have this information which
then builds into hunge and then builds into conceptual knowledge.
The second thing I would like to go on and on these kind of first sweep
through decisions and they're idiosyncrasies and typical things that were wrong,
and when they right and so on.
By the way, let me tell you something which I think, I mean,
there's no way to respond completely this particular answer,
but something that typically comes into a very popular question,
so to say, is what's the right way to decide?
By the right way I mean, in terms of the category of ways of making decisions.
A classical split is between people
that think that you should follow your heart or your intuition.
Other people that think that you have to go all the way in
your decisions to write it down to the last decimal and calculate all what you can.
I think that this tells us very clearly when hunches are good and when they are bad.
Very good in domains in which we do have a lot of statistical information,
and there are some domains that this is true for the majority of the people,
one typical example is social knowledge.
We all have a lot of experience on how people behave.
So social knowledge rightly works on the ground of intuitions,
and it will be complicated to choose who you like to spend your life and so on.
But you know very detailed calculations,
although algorithms now are trying to do so for us.
But the best resource we may have for these highly variable problem,
highly dimensional that cannot be reduced to
simple calculation is to use broad approximate statistical learning.
Other decisions like piloting a plane or doing surgery.
Of course, we want a very highly precise and educated and not rational decision-making.
So this also tells the typical fallacy,
that some people think that they have very good intuition, and this is never true.
Some people think that they have very bad intuition.
This is also not true.
People have both intuitions for certain domains in which they are
educated statistically and they have bad intuitions for domains in which they are naive.
A tennis player will have a good intuitions with tennis maybe,
a farmer we'll have intuitions on weather because that's
something that's relevant for them and that I think can allow them so on,
and different people have good intuitions about different domains.
Now last thing I would like to show you is the idea of confidence.
On the questions we can go more on [inaudible].
Once again, I'm going to make a very, very short excursion,
a very short trip, on this particular domain name into scaffolds.
I like this quote by William saying that this idea
that we should be confident when we know a lot about something,
but that's not what happens,
that's what I showed you here.
We tend to be very confident when we know nothing,
and so we just get glimpses of the data,
but because this is all the data there is,
we forget that there's a lot of ignorance and so we're
extremely confident as spikes of data.
This is a picture by these ideas, obvious,
is what we had before we know it was a problem.
We know the complexity of the problem,
and we know that we should empower our competence.
We may understand more,
but first thing we discover is not understanding,
but also the universe of ignorance.
The biggest demonstration I think there is we have ourselves my lab of demonstrations,
but there's a demonstration by Reynolds which I really like.
I thought also in this mapping symposium was
interesting also to bring this different technology.
It's also pretty popular now.
It's called TMS, Transcranial Magnetic Stimulation,
it works through Faraday law also.
There's a very rapid magnetic field that's induced,
and this induces a current.
It's a very weak current,
but it's enough to make a hole in the brain that can do different things.
One thing is disposed to be unimodal cortex so you
can move your hand. This is very intriguing.
Disulphide a little bit like a puppet,
because there's someone that's actually controlling directly from
your brain and moving your hand.
You can also go into language regions and induce the production of language.
But also you can just produce or build noise in
the brain so scattered current that what we'll do is bring noise.
If this conjecture is true,
then there's a very,
anti-intuitive prediction, which is that as you increase the noise in a problem,
then you know less and you will perform worse but you will be more confident.
This is a typical situation in which people will recognize these,
people tend to be very confident in highly volatile scenarios.
Once again, because they ignore the Aryans and
then there are very strong spikes of data which they grew up
and they feel very attached to this particular subset of the data.
What do you have here is a performance on a perceptual basket.
It doesn't matter the details and as you go higher in the bar,
this is deep prime with this mystical measure of the performance.
This is different people and what you see is people vary in performance
and decent lose the average and this is yet not too interesting.
Then you put noise into the brain and you ask what happens with
performance in this particular pursuit of noise in the visual cortex?
What happens is that people do worse,
and this is what you'd expect.
This is not very interesting,
but at least the method works.
You make people do something and you see that in every single subject,
they do worse when you're injecting noise than the black condition.
Actually there's also, it's
control because there's the same sound and the same situation,
but there's no poles of borane.
Now, the question is, what happens with confidence?
You can see the comparison here,
which is that in this situation in which people do worse, which is the red one,
people are more confidence, so this person is doing worse,
he or she's more confident.
This one is doing worse, but she's more
confident and the same true for every single person,
except for this one here.
You see once again a demonstration of an idea which I think is very interesting and can
be mapped to a simple concept, which is,
we tend to be very confident when we know nothing about something,
because we know nothing about the ignorance that we have about this particular space.
This is what happens very often in decision-making,
which is that we have to make a decision.
This decision involves many different spheres of knowledge.
We are just looking at a particular subset of the data.
We do logic here with a wood inference here,
and then we're very convinced.
But then someone else isn't going at a different portion of the data,
and they're also doing with logic on this particular portion of the data,
but ignoring the rest of the existence of
the data and so they come up with a very different conclusions.
This builds to what we've seen now these days,
which is that people suddenly cannot understand each other and become
two completely different conclusions where the world
seems to be completely polarized to a point that
people seem not to be able to speak one to the other one.
I want to go there on,
like my last slides is on how we can correctly this,
once we understand this phenomenon, how we can correct?
It turns out to be that there is an extremely simple solution,
not rocket science, very simple solution.
Zero technology, which is a significant game changer,
which can improve a lot if the decisions that we
make in simple decisions like making easy calls,
but also the most complicated decisions of our lives.
This comes from an experiment that we did on a huge audience.
This was done in a basket stadium with 10,000 people.
What I will show you is that,
when we had the idea that we're trying to prove here, is that,
if the hypothesis is, as I told you,
that people make bad decisions because they only look at subsets of the data,
then, there is an easy way of correcting this,
which is putting people together.
Because together they are something at different portions of the data,
and so they're getting a better understanding of the errors of reasoning that they're
making because of looking at partial data or making conclusions very rapidly and so on.
There was a simple idea which is that if you get
together with people to think about the problem,
then you'll come up with better decisions.
Not just better in quality,
but also more equanimous and more balanced decision.
This is what we wanted to do and so when we ask these people to make decisions and
then we brought them together in groups of three and five people,
the numbers is very important.
I'll explain in a second why.,
and then people dismayed together this call his decision,
and then they had the opportunity to change their own mind.
Our question was very simple.
What happens in this?
You can see these as a filtering process,
like a course grading process.
You have an idea, then you have a kernel.
I can deep learning, you have a kernel of
different peoples and you lose statistical information,
but somehow you gain resolution or you gain a precision,
so you lose resolution, again,
precision and the question is what happens?
We did this experiment, which is, as I said,
I think remains the biggest public essential experiment in decision-making.
It was very beautiful because there was a particular noise you see here on the right.
How it went, like each one of these is a group
of people that were conversating about twins.
Sometimes like easy things to conversate,
but also sometimes very difficult and things that we
struggle a lot to put into words and to discuss with other people.
The first part of the experiment is very simple.
It was approximate questions and this,
we wanted it to be a model of
the majority of the decisions we make with partial information,
so one question to be,
how many seats are there in the world with a population larger than one million?
Or the question to be, how many times do the Beatles
say yesterday in the song Yesterday?
Or the question to be how many goals were scored in
the last football or soccer World Cup?
Or the question could be,
how many airports are there in the US?
For all these questions, you have an idea.
You know, more or less commonly they are,
but you even don't have to have exact answer,
and if you think this balance as investment for the spec investment problems,
the more precise your calculation then the more likely that you will make a better goal.
People made their goal,
which I mean, you can do yourself,
you can give a try here.
We cannot play the game.
I mean, if we read the word together,
then I would do this experiment with you.
I would ask you to think about it then to get,
to get them in groups and so on,
but that's something that unfortunately we cannot do
here so the answer for this one in particular is for 96.
What we did is,
we looked at what happened and something I'd to tell you is that,
data here, people wrote this in that paper.
They use pencils and paper so nothing sophisticated and
actually our dataset were a huge garbage cans,
a garbage bag, sorry,
huge garbage bags with thousands of
papers which we took and then we digitalize and so on,
and we converted these into science.
What do you see here,
is what was the norm by then?
The norm was a very simple statistical idea, which is that,
if people are unbiased,
which is true for a certain class of problems,
then the more people you get the better
will be your result essentially because there will be noise canceling units.
This is not a statement about people,
this is a statement about statistics,
so it's convergence to the mean.
Some people will think there's more,
some people would think less and as you get more and more people,
this would cancel and eventually converted to any.
Now, because there were many questions and questions we
find had different units that refer to different things.
You have these expressed in terms of normalized errors,
and you see that it does not converge to zero.
The reason it does not converge zeros is
because people in many questions, they are biased.
The majority of the people,
they think that there's more than actually there was so there was less,
so they either overestimate consistently or they underestimate consistently
and this is something that cannot be canceled by aggregating more and more people.
The question was, what happens when we get people together?
There was, imagine there was 1,000 people,
so we've got 1,000 boats and then we can look like coarse-grained,
as I said before, we can get them in groups of five.
Now, we have only 200 groups,
but each group has a better decision.
The question is, is this course graining efficient or not?
The answer is, it's fine efficient.
You see here, which is that actually,
when people get together,
they converge to a decision which is much
better than the decision they had before getting into the group.
This made a lot of noise,
although it may seem very simple,
because there was a very strong belief.
If you think this from a statistical perspective, once again,
for a system to be some statistically you want particles to be independent,
and the moment they get correlated because they start talking to each other,
then you lose statistical information,
and then you get n of redundance,
and then instead of having a 1,000 boats, you have less boats.
But what we're showing here is actually that,
the value of conversation actually was
greater than what you lost by these coarse-grained,
and this change an idea that has stood for many years,
which was that, to make good judgments,
you need people to remain independent.
They do not need to influence one to each other through conversations.
Actually when people came back to
their seats and they had the opportunity to change their minds,
this result was even much better.
This is what you have here, which is the standard error of
individual goals after they have been filled there through conversations.
Let me put all of this together.
I showed you in the first part that our decisions are very
biased and they have all these errors of reasoning.
We only look at part of the evidence.
I could not show all of them, but I showed enough that I
hope was convincing that we make these stereotype errors,
and their problem precisely because they are stereotyped,
we're not aware of them.
How can we be aware of them?
In the moment you have to explain this to someone else.
We asked, what is it that people are doing when they get together?
What we saw, the first thing is that,
if you take all the results,
imagine that you have a group,
like i the number of cities,
and there was like a 400 and 480 and someone responded 75.
The first thing you could do is just the average and this is good enough.
If you were to do this,
then you would get the blue curve.
But the fact that the black curve is better than the blue curve,
is showing that the groups are doing something better than average.
This is interesting because we did not give groups any policy,
and yet it turns out that groups are smarter than they would be
just by pulling their information together in the most classical way.
If you look at all possible mathematical models,
what you get is that what people do is optimal statistically,
which is that they tend to combine information of everybody,
but they do so on a way that's weighted by the confidence.
This is a weighted average by which you give more value to the person that claims
to know more and less value to the person that actually claims to know less.
Second typical robust statistical theme,
is to identify where this is properly rated,
you try to see if the people that have high confidence,
and this I did not have enough time to dwell on.
We can go on to statistics questions are
impostors and you weigh people do that
is because they have high confidence in all questions.
If someone who claims to have high confidence in your questions,
then the group do not use this confidence information.
But if they do so on some questions but not others,
then they begin to use information.
Finally, of course from this average they feed their outlier.
If someone would say that they're like
three million cities with more than one million people,
then groups would say we did not pick this information the average because [inaudible].
This is interesting enough.
But if I look at this information here,
but if I were to put the confidence weighted average,
it will be somewhere between the blue line and
the black line but people do even better than
the best mathematical model to combine the results.
The reason is that people do not combine the results.
They combine the methods by which they reached those results.
They discuss, well,
how did you think this problem?
and then they go, yeah,
but you made an error because looking Europe,
cities are not so populated and they begin questioning
actually the arguments and the reasons that what kind of hidden in the unconscious.
That becomes just monitoring process
by which you make explicit all the arguments that lead to this decision.
Very simple, but very powerful,
is a healthy way of making good decisions and avoiding
these biases is just whenever you have to
make an important decision you look for someone else,
can not be 300 people because that's not the good conversation,
just pick two or three or four people.
Ideally, they have to think different from you so that you will be forced to
explain them the reasonings that led you to this particular choice.
In doing so, you are very likely to find errors than would have been
remained completely unconscious if you did not
go through this particular filtering process.
I'd like to tell you something else because I mentioned the idea I could finish here,
but I would like to tell you one more experiment.
This is the one we did with a dialect.
We also did it in a group with 10,000 people and then with Dan Ariely.
Here the question was very similar to what I just presented.
But it was not on questions that have a ground truth,
and on questions that actually are more in
the domain of morality or ideology or politics.
Those things that we just strongly believe they're right or wrong.
Those things that as I said, are very polarized.
Some people have very strong arguments that made them believe for A,
and some people have very strong arguments that make them for B.
Apparently there's no way,
even less way of putting this together.
I would like to make sure the claim that this is not
an inevitable phase of human dialogue and human interactions.
It's just a consequence of conversations happening in the wrong space,
which is typically space of social networks and
the space of a lot of people shouting at the same time.
I want to make the claim,
scientifically that when people get together in small groups,
then they become more [inaudible],
they become much more malleable and much more open than they actually think they are.
The way we did this experiment is we had dilemma.
This is just one dilemma.
You'll see they're uncomfortable dilemma you can read them.
A Company offers a service that takes a fertilized egg and produces millions of embryos,
with slight genetic variation this allows parents to have child
that shares their combined genomes at the same time selecting their child's height,
eye-color, intelligence, social competence,
and other non-health related issue.
What the company does is and
then you can say it's right or it's wrong according to your beliefs,
each one has a position people feel strongly about.
We had some that were like even much more strongly,
especially when they touch very practical thing and very actual things of human ideology.
Of course not interested in any moral conversation of this.
I'm just interested in what goes on in
the decision process that makes us conclude what we conclude.
Each person would make a different conclusion.
The idea that we may be more malleable and that all of us maybe not seeing as much of
the space of argumentation is that we
think when we get together with someone that feels differently,
then we may change more than we thought.
This is what I will try to show you.
I got three slides to make this.
This was the distribution of this particular population.
This was A, this is nothing universal.
It will change with different people of different ages,
people in different places, it's just a norm.
You see, a lot of people where very zero means is completely wrong.
You see this here that means it's completely right.
You see that in the same space with
people that more or less have the same background and so on.
You have this diversity of someone sitting next to another one,
that one thinks that it's completely
wrong and the other one thinks it's completely right.
The question is, we will put these people together in a group, is it?
and we will ask them to think like they are in an ethical committee,
and their job is to come up with a consent number for these.
Like saying, well, we give it a four,
we give it a six like it's not completely right,
but it's an important thing is it has to be unanimous. It's three people.
The three of them have to sign the paper and say,
I think this is the right thing to do.
They all have the option of saying, no,
I do not want to sign this and they have this opt out.
The question we're asking here,
it's not so much to what consensus they reach the question before,
although we also asked this question,
but the first interesting question here is,
what is the likelihood that they will reach consensus?
For this, something that you have to know,
which is important is that people in
the same way that they distribute their opinions on whether it's right or wrong,
they also distribute their confidence in a way that is predictable,
which is that people that are in the extremes,
they're very short position and the people in the middle which we call the grades,
they doubt more, they are not sure,
and so typically their confidence is way lower.
But you may see here something which actually is still the dilemma,
it's small, but it's still which is the people in the center in the very center,
you have higher confidence.
This is because there is a bimodal distribution
in which there is a population of people that are in the center,
but have very high confidence.
We call these people the high confident grades.
Those are the people that think this dilemma has real reasons for being right,
real reasons for being wrong.
I'm really sure that the right thing to do is to stand
somewhere in a central place in the space of options.
Here you have the distribution of confidence for people.
When people have medium confidence on this,
these are the high confident grades.
Now my last slide,
what happens when we put these A people together?
and of course the likelihood.
The question is, what is the likelihood that they will reach a consensus?
Of course, if we do this as a function of their initial disagreement, and of course,
if the initial disagreement is zero,
meaning that they had the same ideas,
then they naturally reach reachable census.
It's very simple. You think it's wrong,
I think it's wrong, or you think it's right,
I think it's right, we just sign the paper and we go out very rapidly.
Of course, as there is more difference,
this decreases. That's natural.
It's highly expected. The real surprise is that this value,
even with very high disagreement,
is close to 50 percent.
It varies in the question,
goes from 20-60 percent,
but it's always one order of magnitude higher than what people think,
if we ask them,
is the likelihood that they will reach an agreement.
If I were to run this experimentally,
which we've done, and ask people,
what do you think is the likelihood that if I put someone that thinks
this is completely right with someone that this is completely wrong,
[inaudible] 100 of this group,
how many will reach agreement?
People who say one, two, sometimes zero.
Reality is that in the right condition,
people speaking and listening in an open situation and not too many people shouting,
then the likelihood of getting together,
of agreeing to a consensus and to depolarizing,
is much higher than what people would expect.
Once again, conversations converge to rationality
and not to irrationality when they are in their natural habitat, in their right domain.
The last thing is, okay,
50 percent of the groups, but what is it?
Why some do and some don't?
The answer to this, the most important factor,
is whether there is a high-confident gray.
If there's someone in the group that can speak to both parties and say,
you're right, and you're also right,
and look, what he's or what she's saying may have some reason.
There's someone that understands that it's not idiots against intelligents,
in whatever side you want to see the balance going,
but people with arguments from both sides,
then the likelihood of convergence increases substantially.
You see not a huge effect.
It's not like they guarantee that there is likelihood of consensus,
but they increase [inaudible] substantially.
This is a laboratory experiment,
but many people have done these experiments in the grounds.
I think the most interesting experiments are done in the frontier
between Israel and Palestine with the exact same results.
In the moment of most ferocious fights,
the situation where you think there's no way these people will understand,
you put the most radicals from one place and
the most radicals from the other place and you make them talk.
If there's a high-confident gray that
actually gives this perspective of malleability behavior that,
you know what, take out of your mind that your people will not change,
they may change because you're thinking this way,
then groups now in the real ground,
not in this moral-simulated experiments,
are much more likely to reach consensus.
Not only that, but also,
if you measure their likelihood of participating together in collaborative work,
in working in the same enterprises,
future behavior of these people,
it's a complete game changer.
I think that there's something interesting.
I'll close with these, but I began with very sophisticated technology,
fMRI to going to vegetative state patients and preverbal infants and so on,
and how these can help us,
give us information to make very difficult decisions.
Then I went on to say, well,
but this isn't the majority of physicians.
Of course, the decisions happen just very rapidly,
fast and foolish decisions,
and we make all this sort of errors.
In the end, instead of going skeptic on this direction,
which I think we've been very skeptic,
I wanted to give up a note,
not from faked optimism but data that we've been gathering for many years,
that I think should give us at least the idea that
this pessimism of the incapacity of conversations to
solve situation comes from the fact that typically we
have them in the wrong setups and not where they should be.
With this, I thank you very much and I'll pick any of
the questions that you may want an effect. Thank you very much.
Thank you very much, Mariano,
for that fantastic talk.
I have lots of questions myself,
but we open up to the audience.
Please feel free to type your questions in the Q&A.
As people get ready,
if I may, I'd like to ask the first question.
I really, really like your point about how some of
these conversations are happening in the wrong spaces and that we
need to find smaller groups where more malleable opinions can actually be heard.
What I was curious, from what you say,
it sounds like the success in this convergence and
consensus making requires a few persuasive mediators who can talk to both sides.
How do we inculcate such a temperament?
How do we get people to have that frame with which they see issues?
Do you think in educational systems we can do something,
or as a society, or is it really an individual?
Yeah. These, I think, are very good,
and from my view,
at least, very relevant question.
It's been very highly studied,
mostly, as you bring in your intuition in educational setups.
This is typically referred as malleable minds,
or as growth minds is the typical term.
If you were to look in Google Scholar or for references,
the right term would be a mind of growth or growth mind.
The typical problem is,
it's like you give a 10-year-old children a problem
that's just above what they can do so that they can not solve it.
That's typical of science.
In science, we give problems that are just above from what we can do. Children split.
Of course, it's continuous,
but they typically split in two modes of reaction.
It's not a completely categorical split,
but there are like two tendencies.
One is frustrations and like I cannot do it.
Its too hard. This leads to a whole lot of behaviors.
They cheat, they blame others for giving them things that they cannot do,
so they build anger and so on.
Other children, naturally,
and those things vary,
as there are variances in height and eye color and so on,
there is variance also in their disposition,
other children understand that they cannot do it,
but understand that they can get close to it.
That's why it's a mindset about growth because they understand that they
can do something to break this leap between where they are and where they have to be.
These stretches them. Same problem.
Two very different trajectories.
Once again, when this type of inhibition setups,
is that this ends up being very decisive in educational trajectory,
so children that do have this mindsets,
they persist in them,
and they start also to buy food cake.
Because they start being outsiders,
and the ones that do not pass the exams,
and the ones that start believing that they cannot do things,
and they've been longer and so on.
While the other ones are the ones that end up going to the good schools and so on.
Now, the good news,
and that's the response to your question,
is that these things can be changed.
It's not easy, but it's also not hard.
It's not so easy, I mean it's not just the disposition.
It's not just like saying,'' I want to have
an open mindset and then bloom next day, you will have it.''
We have these cognitive illusions,
but this is not true for any form of learning.
It's not like I want to play tennis and next day you play tennis. You have to train it.
In the same way, if you want to have an open mindset, you have to train it.
But it's much easier than playing tennis.
That's the good news. There are many different ways that have been developed,
once again, in most educational setups.
It's been proved that if children in time, you change them,
a fixed mindset to an open or to a growth mindset,
then they are in time to have a better likelihood.
Those things of course, are always probabilistic,
but they have a higher probability of going through a much better educational trajectory.
Thank you. It sounds like this has to be instilled as an aspiration,
even for the kids that don't
naturally have that temperament. That this what [OVERLAPPING].
Yeah it has to be. You have to,
and this is training.
It's not something that you have to learn,
because some people have it granted,
and other people don't.
It's not like there is a default for these.
Then you can go back on, why this happens.
Some of these things may be genetic and so on,
but some of these are also very early implicit training.
Parents building these mentality not in ways that they understand.
Sometimes completely against their will and their desire.
There are different things.
This is a very complicated iterative,
it's not like there's a simple way on how to build this mentality.
I think I'm pointing you to the idea,
and it requires study.
I think it would not be fair if I say I can summarize this in two minutes.
But some ideas we can put in a table.
One that has been known pedagogy for a long time,
is people get frustrated when they have aspirations which are ridiculously high.
Different educational setups work differently in this condition.
One condition is you're always kind,
and there's a very famous pedagogical idea by Lev Vygotsky,
the Russian pedagogue do which is the disown of proximity.
It's the idea that learning has to be just above.
But just above in these problems that I told you,
they are not just above, they're like a significant step above.
Those are the ones that can frustrate you,
and that's not where you should typically have children grow in their educational setup.
This is one reason that will make,
a lot of children make the conclusion
that they cannot solve problems which are more difficult than they can afford,
because they've given problems that they really could not solve because they were so
difficult than they have made
this conclusion because of a wrong sampling history of problems.
This is just one idea of how you can
begin biasing falling in one side of the camp or the other one.
It's complex, but they're substantially territory.
I think that it's one of the cases in which we can make informed policies,
both at large public policies,
but also in parental policies,
like how to grow our Children in a better way.
Thanks, Mariano. It also sounds like this is the thing that you would have to
persistently reinforces when you would have to keep reinforcing.
Yeah, that's why I'm making it always point it's complex.
It's also domain-specific.
Some children, they may have domains in which they have this mentality,
and they know that consult them,
but they are bad in Maths.
As I was saying, intuition,
it's not like there's people with good intuition,
people have different ways of relating with
adversity and with resilience in different domains.
One thing which is also very important to know is that,
and this comes from
a very basic idea
I made the case that we make very rapid conclusions which we trust a lot.
But it's even worse than that because then these conclusions begin
changing us in a way that we confirm the conclusions that we've made.
This happens individually but also socially because we tend to look
for data that confirms the hypothesis that we have already made.
Imagine you're in a point of bifurcation where you can make the claim,
I'm bad at Math or I'm good at Math,
and you're right there, and you'll make your claim.
It's like a bit like measurements in quantum physics.
Once you've made this call and you say I am bad at that,
then you've changed reality,
because once you've made this call,
this is what I like George Soros, the finance.
He started with Opera and he knows a lot of human behavior,
and this is why he's made a lot of money
because he understands how people behave in a very deep way.
It's interesting because the way I think he thinks of
the stock market as the best laboratory of human behavior,
and he keeps them coming [inaudible] this idea which he calls reflexivity.
It's not a new idea, it's an old idea and it's very powerful.
He says that this is one of the central ideas in the market.
The market makes a belief that an action is going,
the stock is going to grow,
and this decision that the market has made changes
reality and the way that now this stock changes,
because people will be consistent with the idea that they've made.
This leads to financial bubbles.
There is a moment in which there is an inconsistency
between people's beliefs and reality,
and then there's an explosion.
The idea we'd like to bring here is that we also have the psychological bubbles.
We tell ourselves a story,
I'm good at this or I'm bad at this and the story builds,
because we sampled data in a way that we look for consistency on that.
Eventually, sometimes it also blows,
but for a long time it gives us the ability of having
completely different mentalities. This is also important.
Sometimes parents, they are not also aware,
like sometimes statements are very heavy,
like saying he's not good at Math.
I'll tell you one that happens to me,
my son he's the one that tends to.
He falls a lot. This is not a typical behavior.
If they go to up to a birthday party and one falls,
and has ache,
typically it's my son because he's not the best control and so on.
I'm very versed on these,
but sometimes I make the error of making a caricature of this,
making fun of this and making, once again.
I know here it tells me that I should never do this because the only thing I'm doing is,
I'm fueling more something that actually begun being self-consistent.
What I'm saying with this is that
sometimes they are very strong biases that are difficult to eradicate.
They take like substantial attentional control
not to fall onto these errors that parents often fall to stigmatize even their children,
which is the last thing they would want to do on Earth,
but sometimes we do, nevertheless.
Really insightful. Thank you so much, Mariano.
Going back to something earlier in
your presentation from one of our frequent participants,
Jenny, she asks, is bouba kiki correspondence a form of synesthesia?
If so does this tell us that everybody is capable of developing synesthesia?
Yes, it is. For those that may not be familiar with the word,
synesthesia means that there's automatic relation between different sensory modalities.
Some people, when they see some shapes,
as we saw here, they believe that they correspond to certain sounds.
But there's also some people that when they perceive certain tastes,
these tastes produce certain sounds or they relate to certain shapes.
So vision, audition, taste, smell,
which normally are independent modalities, they're automatically linked.
What this experiment shows is that we all have certain forms of synesthesia.
Some of those are cultural, for instance.
Another example would be color and temperature.
Most of us think those things a priori are independent but they are not,
and the reason they're not is because their material corresponded,
which is the majority of materials when they are
incandescent and hence they're warm, they're red.
We tend to think that red is hot and that blue,
which is more the color of eyes, is cold,
and this is a form of cultural synesthesia,
which is driven by material experience like the one I showed with the mouth.
Another example which I really like,
and it's in my book Priya which you mentioned,
so you may have read about it,
is the correspondence between time and space which a priori are different entities,
but the majority of the people, and if you think like,
how we use language is you feel like Christmas is approaching.
Is approaching from where?
Like Christmas is in time,
but we have the feeling that it's ahead of us.
If you choose ahead and the past is behind,
this seems like that's just how it has to be like Kiki and Buddha.
But there are other cultures,
I mentioned example of the Imanas which is a culture
in the northwest of Argentina and Bolivia,
and Chile, and this culture has,
in their language, the word for in front also means past.
It's the same word and the word for behind which is naida also means in the front.
It's very interesting because they might as, what they say.
Is that the reason the past is in front is because it's the only thing we know,
and there's this relation between when you want to tell someone,
"Did you understand someone?"
You say, "You see."
Like seeing is understanding, seeing is knowing.
If you use this relation,
the only thing you see, the only thing you know,
the only thing you understand is the past,
and the things that you do not see,
you do not understand and you do not know is
the future with hands is behind, it's in the back.
It's very interesting because we believe that this correspondence,
the steady correspondence between time and space seems very logical,
like the future, we advance to the future that's how it should be.
But someone comes in a different culture
then you know what for me it's the other way around.
There are many other ones like the Aztecs,
they have circular type.
Now it's not only different correspondence between what's ahead and
what's behind but also in the topology of space.
Interestingly, there's also not complete freedom because at all cultures
known use one-dimensional representation for time,
and that's very interesting because it seems to be
as far as we can tell from the way we perceive time,
that this is a physical limitation of how we can organize a certain space.
So there are many examples of synesthesia.
Also very interesting just to tell an anecdote I think maybe because Edward Hubbard,
and Ramachandra, which I mentioned in their paper,
they were doing a lot of the interesting work of the neuroscience of anesthesia.
Edward Hubbard, we did some work together and we're very good friends,
and the problem with working with synesthetics is that it has this flare of genius,
so musicians, they claim that they see music and this gives brilliancy,
or mathematicians, a great mathematician will tell you,
"I can hear the sound of Pi."
I'm not just like the product of work,
I'm a product of genius because I got like these very sophisticated.
So it gives like a sense of poetry,
so people lie on this.
You get a lot of people that come to
the laboratory saying that they are synesthetic which they are not.
There are interesting tests to measure whether someone is genuinely synesthetic or not.
For instance, one is typical synesthesia is people see letters of different colors.
So like Ls will be blue and As will be red.
You say, perfect. So now do the
following and you give them a maze which is full of Ls and there's one A,
and if you're not synesthetic this is very hard because it requires a lot of attention,
but if it's red on green,
then this just pops out and it's very rapid.
Some people are real synesthetics and these people,
they just can find it in a fraction of a
second independently of how many destructors there and so on,
while some people claim they're synesthetics but in truth they are not.
There are many more interesting stories about synesthesia but we could go a very long.
That's fantastic.
So there's a question from Victoria who asks,
how has information from
the Myers-Briggs personality evaluation
been incorporated into any of these studies? If it has.
Can you repeat the question because I'm not sure I understood it?
The information from the Myers-Briggs personality evaluation
has not been incorporated into any of these studies?
I don't know. Sorry, I will not be [inaudible]
There this personality tests that you can take that cost you into certain combinations.
Yeah, this is a research I would not like to speak
about something that I am sure there is information on that,
but not that I'm aware and that's the limit of my knowledge.
I would be speaking colloquially,
that's not something that I know sufficiently
to provide an informed answer. I'm very sorry.
No worries. One of our fellows,
Tyler wrote us,
are there still confident gray positions
for situations in which there is no natural middle point?
What happens, for instance,
if you ask groups to point towards Vladivostok,
or guess in what direction the hour hand on the clock there is pointing.
Yeah. This is very interesting.
This is very interesting because
we've not done the confident grades on problems like this sort,
that have a concrete and real ground truth.
There's a solution and they have particular distributions
where there are Gaussians, they may be shifted.
The confident grades are, I think,
interesting in problems in which the distribution of beliefs is typically by model.
We've shown, actually,
in a specific paper that how people build
confidence on these problems and how people build
confidence on perceptual problems like pointing to [inaudible] stock,
leads to very different distributions,
which leads to very different ways in which confidence is being constructed.
Essentially, the main difference it has to do with
the idea from what's the universe from which they sample data.
Typically, in polarized problems,
it is as if this is a model,
this is a very simplified model so
that I'm not speaking exactly how it works in our brain,
but a model in which you let people sample from two different distributions, arguments.
Imagine the genetic problem I gave,
so the arguments in favor would be,
we try to make the best for our children and we use the arguments we have,
we use education, why not use genetics?
I'm not saying this is right, I'm saying this is an argument.
An argument against would be like,
this will lead to Aryan like the typical genic nightmare.
We will all converge to monochromatic humans.
What I'm trying to say is that those arguments,
you see, they're very discreet,
and I could pick many more,
but they seem to be picked from their very different bats.
It builds up all this vision,
in which you may have a number of arguments from
this bag and a number of words from this bag,
and then people that are the high confident grades are
the one that actually sample from both of them,
and the ones that are below confident grades are
the ones that actually have very low sampling,
so essentially they don't understand the problem and they think it's
just too complicated and they then don't want to think about it.
It's a very different perspective.
I don't think the high confident grade argument would work for unimodal distributions.
Like in the problem,
I forgot the name,
he or she mentioned,
like the bloody pointing to [inaudible]
stock problems that are typically perceptual problems.
This has not been shown and I don't think it would work there,
I think the intuition is right.
I think we have a good reason to understand why it would not work,
which again its confidence is constructed very differently in these problems.
Thank you. Next question from the audience,
can you tell us something more on the shaping of reality generated by a claim that we do?
It seems that we convince ourselves of something and then
we subconsciously make decisions that confirm the claim.
Yeah. Let me give you
one example because I mentioned the wrong conversations from Twitter and so on.
There are a lot of correlations between
the actions that we make and the beliefs that we have.
It's been known for years that people like,
and actually we just have a paper on this,
people like other people that think like them.
This is very universal, it's very conserved.
Of course, you should not take this argument as you
will not like someone that thinks differently from you.
It's a statistical argument that we tend to like more,
we tend to prefer, and we tend to have many, many more friends.
Actually, each of you in the audience can do the experiment.
How many people around you do you have that think
radically different from you like in first question, second question?
Take 15 different problems like taxes,
abortion, drugs, foreign policy.
Take a number of them and think how you think about all of them.
Think how the majority of the people think about these people.
If you're like the majority of people,
you'll find a very strong correlation.
You do agree on a lot of problems that when you think about them,
they are really independent problems.
Me being liberal on this does not imply that I
have to be liberal on this and I can be conservative of this other.
But we tend to be very partisan.
I say we tend is a statistical finding
that the vast majority of the people are like this.
Interestingly, those are experiments done in sociology.
The more educated the people they are,
the more correlated they are.
If you take in the US the axes of what Democrats think about a particular problem,
what's a typical Democrat reaction to any particular problem?
What's the typical Republican?
This is 20 years ago,
now Republican, it's spreads in axis.
But typically when really there was a two-dimensional layout of political spread,
the most of the violence in the US.
Then you spread people in these domains, and you ask,
how much people look alike,
how correlated they are,
and you measure this as a function of education.
The more educated people they are,
the more correlated they are,
the more they begin to think alike because they form these tribes in which why is this?
This is a response to your question because they're intelligent people.
I speak in third person, but I make all these emirs,
I'm not excluded from any of these.
But we tend to listen arguments that
we unconsciously gather to confirm our beliefs because this is very comfortable.
How this happens,
we did one study which I think at least to me it was
very enlightening on the complexity of this problem.
Because this is true, of course,
this is worse in social networks because
people in social networks follow who they want to follow,
and so they get a lot of evidence that confirms what they want to do, which is true.
Take vaccines.
I'm vaccinated,
I'm completely in favor of vaccines.
Here I'm going to say my [inaudible], it's not important,
but if there's information,
some information that shows that vaccines do cover risk.
The obvious fact for this is that, for instance,
I'm sure I want to vaccinate myself,
I do not think I would like to vaccinate a six month old baby.
This is just a recognition that I understand that there are arguments against it.
In my opinion, the arguments in favor are much more sound and hence I make my conclusion.
But if I only were to look at these arguments,
and this is, once again,
the only space I'm looking for,
I will rationally make a conclusion that this is the wrong thing to do because I
do have papers and evidence that show all what I want to
see that proves that I have to stand where I do stand.
How does this work in social networks?
There are fact-checking companies that
understood this problem and so they said we need to provide balanced evidence.
We need to provide evidence showing that the good people do good things,
the good people do bad things,
the bad people do good things and the bad people do good things,
so that people understand that reality is more complex.
Perfect. Now, what happens?
You can see this as a distribution of evidence,
so against the favor or against the divide mobile evidence, I would say.
You can think about vaccines.
You should vaccinate because of these,
but you should worry because of this, you should do it because of this,
but beware with that,
and it's providing all the evidence. Now, what is the problem?
The problem is that these companies have like say, one million followers.
But then the followers of these companies retweet
or re-share the information that they get to 50 million people.
This 50 million people do not receive directly from the fact-checking company,
they receive it from who they want to receive it.
It's like a rectifier.
This company is showing balanced information,
but then there are social rectifiers that
fill the information and only let this one pass,
and there are people that are downstream from
this rectifiers because they have this belief,
they have the belief that vaccines are wrong,
so they only follow people that provide information that consume this vaccine,
and they get more and more convinced.
Once again, I want to make the claim,
it's not like they are thinking wrong,
they are thinking on the wrong subset of the data.
This is wrong, but restricted to this particular constraint,
the conclusions that they often make are right,
are the right conclusions from just looking at a small subset of the data.
This is a very clear example of how, once you have a belief,
you decide to sample data on a way that only confirms the beliefs that you had,
and you gather real data that actually will
prove more and more that you are right to think that.
Even when you have a broader set of data available,
you gravitate towards the bits of data.
Yeah. This is also very typical.
Even exactly, this is very important to what you're saying.
We tend to think this as irrationality,
but this is in the essence of science.
When we make the typical scientific claim
of great claims imply or require great evidence,
like if I want to say that the speed of light is not constant,
then I really should have a lot of evidence.
Why? Because we have a strong belief, a strong prior,
if you think this as Bayesian thinking,
like I do have a lot of aggregated knowledge that tells me.
So if I do have information of
the same value in favor of what I
have a strong prior and against what I have a strong prior,
Priya as you were saying, I would not weigh them in the same manner.
This is exactly what you'd expect from
a rational Bayesian thinker, this is the thing they do.
There's one more question that I want to take which sounds intriguing.
The question is from Brad in the audience,
he says, thank you so much for your presentation.
Your response to that MBA question about personality types made him curious,
and he wants to know, how has your work been
received by psychologists working on emotional intelligence?
The president of our university, Peter Salovey,
is one of the originators of this idea of EQ and emotional intelligence.
What I mentioned there is not my work.
Today I was careful of saying what part of the research I showed was my work.
The work on the two papers on decision-making were my work,
and then the extension of
these two educational setups in my ability frameworks and so on,
a lot of famous people have done this,
but this is not my work.
We've done work in education showing same ideas,
but not exactly this.
I don't know the answer. The answer is that because this is not my work,
I don't know exactly how it would be received by.
But because I would like to respond,
I want to respond tangently to this question to something that I think is a bit related.
Emotional intelligence like generals intelligence like IQs or EQs,
they are very controversial.
I think we'll understand the reasons for instance,
now there is a group of researchers,
I think that the champion of this research would be Lisa Feldman Barrett.
She has a very interesting book called How Emotions are Made,
and I think she would be a very good speaker for this symposium.
She makes a very strong claim that emotions
are completely different than the way we think about them.
In particular, she makes the claim that in the same way that I told you that,
we think that the future has to be a head and the past has to be behind,
we think that this has to be anger,
and this is happiness.
She claims that this is wrong, and she claims this from data,
it's not an unfair data,
is that actually if you look at the typical tests used for emotional intelligence,
which is our ability to separate these from this would be sadness.
A very strong cultural conventions that have very fuzzy mappings,
much more fuzzy than it has been claimed.
They are different in different cultures.
She claims it's not true that all babies express them and understand them,
it's not true that, there's a controversy.
This controversy comes in the end in an issue of definitions.
My point there, both for IQ and for Emotional Intelligence,
my understanding is a broad view of all the data.
I think that all the data shows consistently,
there's consistency between how people express emotions in different cultures,
and in different traditions,
and different ages, and different backgrounds,
but also it's not completely universal,
there are exceptions, there are very clear exceptions.
These out for them, mark has a very nice example,
she shows the face of Serena Williams when she won the US Open.
If you see that, she's like really angry,
but she's not angry, she's next essence.
She says, the intensity of the emotion,
we confuse them and we can reappraise
this emotion and we understand it and really signified in a completely different way.
I think my impression,
and here I'm saying my impression,
because before I was saying I think what the paper said,
but now it says it's a space in which the paper say different things.
This happens many times in science.
When this is the case,
I think that you have to understand that there's more variability,
and more complexity in the distributions,
and more lack of understanding and clear definitions that builds this incompatibility.
This may be, sorry, a bit of a long answer,
but if it goes down to say that I think
that part of very big discussions between these fields.
In the end are because we do not have
yet mature and good definitions of what an emotion is,
of what sadness is,
of what emotional intelligence is.
Whatever attempt someone makes to do it,
like the examples you are making or like Ekman and all the famous examples,
are prone to failure like all science.
I myself, I'm very sympathetic,
because I think they need to be done,
and it's an approximation and they will fail like all scientific models have failed,
this one are more likely to fail again because the territory is highly variable.
I think we have to pursue this direction,
but not stubbornly,
but understanding that as all scientific model,
is the best approximation that we have,
it's the best that we can do with the data we have.
We hold it, We have to be open,
and once again malleable,
and understand that we have not to stick religiously to
it because it's our baby model and the one we constructed.
But in the moment that it does not hold to the evidence
and there's sufficient contradiction that we need
a better model than its time eventually to change.
I think you've captured very nicely
the provisional nature of knowledge and science, basically.
What you know at any given time is the best to date
and has limitations and you have to be aware of the limitations.
Therefore you have to be willing to change your mind as you get better data,
more evidence as you said,
you have to build a more refined conceptual model.
I could keep going on,
I have so many more questions,
but I think we need to close with one final question,
which is Jenny Wagner asking again,
"Following up on the bifurcation of decisions,
is there any neurological reason why any change of decision after
the first one has been taken happens more often abruptly instead of slowly.
For example, going suddenly feeling,
being good at math's after all,
when having solved the one difficult problem?"
I'm not sure. I saw two different answers to this question,
I'm not sure either of them except one,
but so one thing is because you
mentioned the brain evidence that so far I've been speaking about psychological evidence.
There's a lot of neural evidence for all what I've been describing,
and this comes from a way that a lot of
neuroscience has changed in the last years in how decision-making progresses,
which is on a highly variation strategy.
There are many demonstrations [inaudible], for instance,
in Geneve would be I think that the best person to look for this information,
showing that you can account for a lot of strange things and decision-making.
If you look at the neural circuits as doing Bayesian computations.
This is the essence of the self-fulfilling prophecy,
because you make a prior and once you make a prior,
you sample evidence prior as you exactly describing it in an unbalanced manner.
There is neural evidence showing that once you've committed to a decision,
then neural circuits change on a way that they decide differently.
It's not a magical construction,
this is implemented in a way that we understand in neurons.
The second thing is this idea that there's
a roll of all these decisions being much faster.
At least what comes to mind to me,
I'm not sure this is exactly the answer you're looking for,
people have studied this very nicely in the history of wall sport records.
There are many records that have not been broken for years and years.
Then eventually they're broken, once they're broken,
there is a very rapid repetition,
the cleanest example is running one mile in less than four minutes.
I think that's which was no one could do it,
then 40 years ago,
somebody did that, and since then there was like 1,400 people,
it had happened already,
but before that for 40 years, no one did it.
As of course there's an issue of technology,
but it's not only technology because it's really this game changer,
this bifurcation and the explanation for these,
once again, it's only the force of
our own minds to convince ourselves of what we can do and what we cannot do.
I would like to tamper this,
because it's not like I say,
I want to fly and then I fly.
This is by no means, it's obvious,
but I want to state I'm not
predicating here that dream about something then it would come true.
This is not the case, people live in very bad realities,
and they struggle,
and they cannot do better than they do.
But there's, this said,
there's much more margin than we think for the range of beliefs,
for the reasons I just explained in our own performances and in our own decisions.
On a way that once we understand that something is doable,
they believe that it could not be done is eradicated,
then this is a game changer that then builds on a rapid cascade.
This is an example from social sciences, so to say.
But I think it's the best example for the psychological question that you were asking.
Thank you so much.
There's absolutely fascinating talk and thank you so much for taking
the time to thoughtfully answer all these questions.
I really should draw us to a close because we are over our time.
Thank you so much Mariano once again for coming and giving us this wonderful talk.
Very thought-provoking and hopefully we all leave here aspiring to have as
malleable a mind as possible to make our ways in the world.
Thank you so much.
Let's give Mariano a really round of applause virtual applause.
Yes. Thank you.
Thank you so much Priya.
Thank you Mariano.
Thank you.